you are a product  of all who came before you  [Music]  i've left in the shadows  [Applause]  but now  it's time to show them  who i really am  i'm ready hell yeah  marvel studios shangqi and the legend of  the 10 rings rated pg-13 get tickets now  for thousands of years  the ten rings  gave our family  legendary power  my son  now  they call to you  i'm not who you think i am  marvel studios shangti and the legend of  the ten rings rated pg-13  if i die it's your fault  september 3rd  [Music]  i'll buy you some time just keep going  um  [Music]  it's time to prepare for battle come on  stretch out those legs  leave fear behind you got this put on  those sparkly shoes  what battle are you preparing for  a dance battle what are you preparing  for oh no no no this is this is like an  epic battle between good and evil  oh right okay okay okay so get your  tickets now for marvel studios shangqi  and the legend of the ten rings  you